[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  it's a very painstaking process trying  to pick the right produce to to make  these core sounds really kind of come to  life on the screen  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  some of the unique challenges in making  sounds for horror movies come from  trying to harness the actual real-world  sounds of the pain or gore which are  actually quite subtle but you find that  those elements are the things that creep  people out the most  [Music]  [Applause]  zombies have become so popular in  mainstream movie culture and television  culture that we've got this huge history  of zombie movies to kind of call upon I  really like the stuff that air is closer  to what reality would be or maybe more  of the quarry zombies that are more  guttural and Flemmi and those are the  things that scare people a little bit  more than the zombie movies of all  [Music]